[Music]
[Applause]
hey everybody welcome to Orbitz report
your source for everything happening
around the world in entertainment and
pop culture news I'm Heather roof and mi
Anna waves and this is your news for
Monday August 14th first up we have to
talk about Disney announcing their very
own streaming service that will come out
in 2019
now they recently did a beta test in the
UK called Disney life and they've been
doing that for a couple years now it
seems to be going well so a lot of
people are wondering if maybe their
streaming service here is going to be
similar the TV movies and then also live
streams also since Disney owns ESPN ESPN
is now coming out with their own
streaming service and that'll be coming
out in 2018 and this game is a little
bit of a surprise considering that
Netflix and Disney just made a deal this
year to have some of their more updated
licenses on Netflix so they're a 1 on
there right now and Doctor Strange and
it's rumored that Netflix is going to
try to hold on to some of the Marvel and
Star Wars licenses that they have this
should be interesting to see how
contract negotiations were suppose
Disney also released this week a 15
second teaser trailer for the big hero 6
television show that's going to be on
Disney XD starting in November now is
only 15 seconds so we didn't really get
to see too much it was just a hero and
baymax kind of looking over the skyline
of San fransokyo but it is something I'm
excited about I enjoyed the movie and
it'll be nice to see their antics
together after I some some long form
antics Yeah right and also this weekend
Disney premiered also on Disney XD the
one-hour pilot of the new ducktales
animated TV series and it came out to
some great reviews people are really
enjoying it saying it's witty and funny
and if you are a fan of the original
cartoon like I am you'll get a lot of
those callbacks to the
original cartoon and the first pilot
episode that we saw this weekend was
aptly named woohoo which you can't even
just say you got you got extinct this
was just kind of a little taste for us
the actual series isn't coming until
September but they wanted to guess what
our palates to entice us to buy Disney
XD if you don't to rehab it that's right
you can watch it now just the pilot and
then get Disney XD then watch the rest
of ducktales get some some big hero 6 in
there yeah all on Disney XE perfect also
in television news a farewell a swan
song if you will to the orphan black
show it was their finale this past
weekend which I haven't watched will see
when I watch it I have a problem with
sledding shows go especially that show
it's incredible the lead actress Tatiana
brings it like every week and sometimes
I genuinely don't understand how they
shoot that show she plays so many
characters other she played so good good
and they're all so guys incredible I'm
sad to see it go but I'm sure they're
giving it a lovely tribute yeah I guess
you'll just have to wait and see when
you're ready Ayanna I'm not ready when
you're right
also in TV news the Tim and Eric awesome
show
good job is having a 10-year reunion
special that's going to premiere in a
couple of weeks on Adult Swim
specifically on August 27th at midnight
and the thirty second trailer I guess
we'll call it that they released this
week showed Tim and Eric's driving
around in little toy Lamborghinis and
singing a song on about it so I'm sure
that fans of the show will definitely
see some of the absurdist humor that
they've come to expect from the Tim and
Eric awesome show good job yeah in movie
news that Lucille Ball biopic that is
going to be titled simply Lucy and Desi
has rumors that possibly they've casted
dizzy with Javier Bardem will sees that
ends up being the final casting but a
lot of people are talking about how to
use Spanish not Cuban as says he is so
it should be interesting to see who they
end up going with you
that's really really look like Chevy so
if he was pretty much a spot-on you know
double I could maybe see it so it's
interesting to see who they're going to
finally cast there's no shooting dates
announced although you know that depends
on casting of course and they do have
the blessing of Lucy and of these
children so it's moving forward for sure
so it would be interesting to see when
it comes out yeah another title that
maybe getting a reboot is Terminator
James Cameron has said that he is
interested in shooting more Terminator
movies once he gets the rights back in
2019 they are still writing the script
exploring where to take it so he's not
sure if it's going to be one movie or a
full trilogy we're just going to have to
wait and see I guess until 2019 when he
officially gets the rights back so this
will be interesting considering that he
gave away the rights because he thought
there were no more stories to tell
within the universe but he did say I'll
be bought no I mean we should have known
yes also the Terminator 2 is going to be
back in theaters for very limited
engagement August 25th at select
theaters in three days so if that's
something you're interested in make sure
to check it out and see if your local
theater is going to be hosting one of
those screenings that's right in huge
movie news seems like Justice League
reshoots have been a bit more involved
than we were originally anticipating
Whedon is now in charge of the filming
of Justice League and they've been going
through reshoots but it looks like
cyborg has had a lot more reshoot so it
sounds from what we've heard is that
he's going to go through a lot of
different character changes possibly not
be so Snyder each dark serious yeah and
be more we'd need middle-ground fun
mm-hmm that sounds about right yeah they
were saying that maybe he might be the
middle ground between the flash and his
goofiness right and someone super
serious like Batman which will be good
we need that kind of transition from
silly series right so it should be
interesting to see what those reshoots
haven't
for his character yeah also they have
hired Danny Elfman's a composer in
addition to their original junkie XL who
you might know from Simon for Superman
although he did help with the Wonder
Woman theme that's right ads that wasn't
bad at framing right right so that would
be a huge tonal shift to add Danny
Elfman in addition to someone like
junkie XL who is very right into the
heavy metal guitar riff and Danny Elfman
is a little bit more I get to call
traditional superhero movie score
although the thing we can hope for is
maybe a little call back to that Batman
theme we love that flavor leave it honey
for me for all of hurt all of us also in
the original snyder version
there was no homeless justice so we
found out there will now be a Hall of
Justice thanks to Eden so are you gonna
do justice league and not have any like
little season a peek at the Hall of
Justice
I find that strange but don't worry we
have one we're gonna see it no no thanks
we did
speaking of DC Batman had a couple of
new movies coming out or hinted at here
this week first of all we got a trailer
for Batman vs to face which was almost a
little hard to watch at least for us
because one of the last things that Adam
West ever was a part of before his
passing so this has Adam West playing
Batman it's got a little bit more of
that corny miss that we expect from the
Batman 66 kind of iteration of him and
two-face is actually also going to be
voiced by William Shatner so we've got a
lot of big names attached to the project
so it looks fun entertaining if you're a
fan of the Adam West Batman make sure to
check it out it's dropping sometime in
the fall of this year the animation on
that looks really cool too like the
design in Catwoman all-time I love it
love it also this evening I will be
seeing Batman and Harley Quinn which is
the
newest animated movies that will be
coming out salmon
Nightwing they have to partner up with
Harley Quinn to defeat poison ivy so I'm
very excited I've got on my Batman
stockings in the celebration and I was
it going to that tonight so let me know
in the comments down below if you will
also be seeing that yeah and also
happening this week there's going to be
a Cheetos pop-up restaurant happening in
New York it's only gonna be three days
August 15 16 17 and it's in a
collaboration with Food Network chef and
Burrell what would seems like an odd
choice come on guys Yeti you should be
here on there to flavortown flamin hot
cheetos you wear flames on your shirt
you got plenty for hair not really but
it's just like a natural partnership
it would seem right I mean Anne Burrell
is a pretty legitimate chef and some of
these menu items sound very interesting
that there was a flaming hot lemon
chicken taco which seemed interesting to
me I'm try that okay and then they also
have dessert items like the white white
cheddar and Cheetos Fritos Apple crepe
hmm no no that's too much of this be in
favor either being odd yeah we'll see we
would say you can check it out but you
can't know called Al's or we also uh
still seems interesting if you're
interested in checking it out though on
August 15th they're going to release the
cookbook for everything that they have
there so you can't still check that out
if you're going to cook any of it let us
know send us pictures oh yeah I'd love
to see that um if they want to share
with us on social media oh where could
they do that other well you can find me
on Twitter at Heather ruse Instagram at
H roof or twitch at twitch.tv slash
others that's right and then you can
find me on Facebook at Ayanna Wade and
then I've made it easy for you guys
Instagram Twitter snapchat all that just
awesome I on across the board very easy
to find we also wanted to announce that
the orbit report will be attending with
the world and that's going to be August
25th through 27th so if you're going to
be in Chicago for that
please come say hi we'd love to talk to
you we'll be
out and around and hoping to interact
with you all that's right so I guess
that's all from us here at the Orbitz
report until next week bemis up
[Applause]
you